>>Jon: The Flipped
class requires us
to fundamentally rethink
two important aspects
of education, space and time.
>>Aaron: So let's talk a
little bit about space.
If you think about the way
classrooms have been set
up traditionally.
They had a chalkboard in
the front of the classroom.
And then those chalkboards
become white boards.
And then those white boards
became overhead projectors,
which then turned
into LCD projectors
that we hung on the ceiling.
But really the classroom in all
of those situations is
a presentation station.
It's not a center of learning.
When we rethink the
space of the classroom,
we're reorienting how
the classroom is used,
where the front of the
classroom is or where the front
of the classroom isn't.
>>Jon: All you have to really do
is rethink where are you going
to put tables and chairs.
But then that begs a very
interesting question,
now what do you do with the
extra time you're going to have
in a Flipped classroom
with the kids?
>>Aaron: The short answer is
we don't know what the best use
of your face-to-face
class time is.
But what we want to encourage
you to do is to think
about ways you can get your
students engaged in some
of the higher order
thinking, the higher tiers
of Bloom's Taxonomy, the
analysis and application
and evaluation and
creation components all
within the context
of the content
that they've already learned
before they come to class
in better ways with an expert
in the room, a contentary expert
and a learning expert.
And that expert is you.
>>Jon: This probably
sounds familiar,
project-based learning,
PBL, universal design
for learning, inquiry learning.
These learning pedagogies
fit greatly
in a Flipped Learning
environment.
>>Aaron: In short, a Flipped
classroom is a way for teachers
to transition into the
role of facilitator,
becoming that guide on the side.
We really see the Flipped
classroom as a transitional tool
for educators to move away from
being the center of attention
in the classroom and move
that attention onto students
and onto the learning that's
happening in those classrooms.
>>[ applause ]